[Applaus]
[Musik]
der asiatisch wird sich zu schrauben ist
zur wichtigsten weltregionen unseres
zeitalters geworden wie wir euch bereits
in früheren videos erklärt haben kommt
es im kampf um die kontrolle dieser
region zwischen den usa und ihren
verbündeten auf der einen und china auf
der anderen seite nicht nur darauf an
wer die größere anzahl an militär basen
hat sondern auch wer seine waffen besser
einsetzt und neue technologische
fortschritte besser zu nutzen weiß wir
haben es in der tat mit einer gewaltigen
rüstungswettlauf zur militärischen
eskalation in der region zu tun und ja
die usa mögen immer noch einen großen
vorsprung haben aber glaubt mir die
chinesen haben so einige asse im ärmel
[Musik]
in der vergangenheit hatte die
chinesische armee große probleme sich
mit fortschrittlichen waffen
auszustatten die es ermöglichen würden
einen so starken gegner wie den
vereinigten staaten gegenüber zu treten
genau aus diesem grund um diesen
nachteil auszugleichen bestand china
strategie im wesentlichen darin auf
quantität zu setzen das heißt eine sehr
große truppenzahl aufzustellen die es
dem land ermöglichen würde seine grenzen
zu schützen als abschreckung für
mögliche angriffe zu fungieren und in
benachbarten terrain zu operieren das
haben wir zum beispiel im koreakrieg
gesehen als eine riesige armee von etwa
800.000 chinesischen freiwilligen in den
krieg zog um die truppen des
nordkoreanischen diktators kim il sung
zu unterstützen in der modernen
kriegsführung die vollen
kommunikationssatelliten und präzision
schlägen dominiert ist diese art von
kampfkraft natürlich immer weniger
relevant ich spreche hier bei über die
erfolgsfaktoren während des kriegs nicht
über jene in der nachkriegszeit dass
diese eine ganz andere sache darstellt
konnten wir im irak oder in afghanistan
beobachten
tatsache ist dass die chinesische armee
angesichts freundlicher logisch so
fortschrittlichen konkurrenten wie den
usa was wird korea japan und australien
keine andere wahl hatte als sich
entscheidend zu reformieren sagt jan
befindet sich die volksbefreiungsarmee
in einem veränderungsprozess dessen ziel
es ist die truppe von grund auf neu zu
erfinden ein übergang von der idee des
soldaten als rückgrat der armee zur
dominanz des hightech als den
wesentlichen kern der streitkräfte das
datum an dem dies erreicht werden soll
ist ebenfalls festgelegt dass jahr 2049
aber natürlich verfügt auch ein
riesenreich china nicht über genügend
ressourcen um alle träume seiner macht
habe erfüllen zu können wir haben hier
bereits in einem firmenvideo erklärt
dass der unterschiedliche militärbudget
zwischen den usa und china viel größer
sein könnte als es auf den ersten blick
aussieht mit anderen worten die
chinesische führung musste sich
entscheiden auf welche art von krieg sie
sich spezialisieren will die frage die
ihr euch sicher alle stellt lautet also
mit welchen waffen typen wollen die
chinesen den asiatisch pazifischen raum
dominieren was genau haben sie im sie
nun eher im grunde genommen selbst das
chinesische regime auf konventionelle
luftüberlegenheit durch tarnkappen
technologie und sogenannte new concept
weapons
diese waffen neuartigen konzepts lassen
sich in drei unterkategorien unterteil
energie wasser also strahlen waffen wie
laser aber auch im push technologie
informations waffen wie computerviren
und heck systeme und drittens
biologische und chemische waffen wie zum
beispiel gentechnisch veränderte viren
okay ich weiß was du jetzt denkst über
biologische waffen haben bereits ein
video gedreht in welchem du antworten
finden wirst auch so manche frage die
wir jetzt durch den kopf schwirrt du
kannst erst ihr über den link in der
beschreibung oder über das symbol oben
rechts ansehen und vergesst bitte nicht
wieso alle politik zu abonnieren und
auch das glück ist aktivieren um in
zukunft keines unserer informativen wie
du es mehr zu verpassen ich danke dir
aber zurück nach china tatsache ist dass
forscher der chinesischen armee seit
jahren in jedem dieser drei bereiche
arbeiten ihr ziel ist die entwicklung
einer innovativen kriegsmaschinerie
gegen der lage ist auf die effizienteste
weise anzugreifen ein vielfaches an
schaden zu verursachen und dabei sogar
noch unsichtbar zu bleiben viele von
euch haben vielleicht noch nie etwas von
einigen dieser waffen gehört die
deutsche zeigen werden denn in diesem
video wird es nicht um flugzeugträger
fregatten panzer oder irgendwas was die
aus den zwanzigsten jahrhundert kennen
also spitzt die ohren
strahlend kanonen und impuls bomben
sicher habt ihr alle schon von
laserwaffen gehört noch vor wenigen
jahren klang diese idee wie etwas aus
star wars aber heute ist in der
militärischen welt eine real
existierende waffentechnologie und wird
in verschiedenen entwicklungsphasen von
armeen wie den der usa russlands und ja
natürlich auch chinas getestet
laserwaffen sind jedoch nur ein rad und
technologie innerhalb einer breiteren
waffen kategorie jede der gerichteten
energie waffen oder strahlen waffen es
geht um waffen der nächsten generation
deren geschosse nicht mehr fest sind
neben laserstrahlen regen wird zum
beispiel auch über plasma mit anderen
worten sie verschießen keine projektile
wie wir sie normalerweise kennen und das
ist hat erhebliche vorteile
andererseits kann ihr einsatz potenziell
viel billiger sein wenn sie erst einmal
produziert sind weil sie keine munition
brauchen und andererseits können sie
durch heutige abwehrsysteme nicht
gestoppt werden außerdem handelt es sich
um sehr präzise waffen die weniger
kollateralschäden verursachen aber haben
sie denn auch nachteile nun im grunde
ist ihr größter nachteil wohl die
tatsache dass sie genau wegen dieser
genannten faktoren niedrige kosten und
geringen abwehrfähigkeit gegen sie
gegenüber konventionellen waffen eine
wesentlich gefährlichere bedrohung
darstellen vor allem wenn sie den
evolutionssprung schaffen denn die
armeen der großmächte in zukunft
anstreben im fall von china hat das land
2017 ein laserwaffen system namens
silent hunter vorgestellt das system
wurde von poly technologies entwickelt
einem teil der staatlichen china pmi
group corporation diese waffe besteht
aus einer laserkanone die auf einem lkw
montiert ist und mit elektrischem strom
betrieben wird bei maximaler leistung
kann der laser eine reichweite von vier
kilometern erreichen oder dabei an
zerstörungskraft zu verlieren um die
eine vorstellung von seiner leistung zu
geben er ist in der lage fünf
stahlplatten von je 2 mm dicke aus einer
entfernung von 800 metern zu
durchdringen oder eine einzelne platte
von fünf millimetern wenn wir die
entfernung auf einen kilometer erhöhen
übertragen auf die realität würde das
bedeuten dass der silent hunter in der
lage wäre selbst leicht gepanzerte
fahrzeuge in einem hypothetischen aber
unwahrscheinlich den bodenkampf auf
kurze distanz anzugreifen die
schlüsselfrage ist nun wo zu china
dieses system braucht nun in der theorie
scheint es sich nicht um eine
angriffswaffe zu handeln sondern eher
das gegenteil
da ist aber noch etwas
interpretationsspielraum denn die
rivalität zwischen indien und china
könnte dazu führen dass diese
technologie zum hauptdarsteller wird
einerseits könnte dieser laser and noch
nützlich sein um drohnen aus niedriger
höhe abzuwehren drohnen sind zu einer
schlagkräftigen waffe geworden wie wir
zum beispiel in krieg zwischen
aserbaidschan und armenien sehen konnten
die drohnen bedrohung könnte jedoch
durch eine geeignete laser auf der
schnell neutralisiert werden und das
blatt wenn aber haben wir es hier mit
einem solchen laser abwehrsystem zu tun
[Musik]
nun mit einer reichweite von einem
kilometer bei maximaler leistung wird
ist gegen die modernsten militär drohnen
mit einer flughöhe von 15.000 meter nur
sehr begrenzt einsatzfähig sein nach
angaben pekings soll ist daher vorerst
nur dazu dienen und sensible
einrichtungen oder gar
massenveranstaltungen vor nicht
autorisierten drohnen zu schützen wie
zum beispiel eine terroristische
bedrohung darstellen könnten allerdings
haben sich die vereinigten staaten
bereits darüber beschwert dass china
dieses oder ähnliche systeme eingesetzt
hat um piloten von c 130 hercules
flugzeugen während ihres fluges über
dschibuti wo china eine militärbasis in
außerdem verhält zu blenden was bei
einigen dieser us piloten gar zur
augenverletzungen führte aber angeblich
ging es laut chinesischer seite nur um
waffentests na klar wie dem auch sei
diese laserwaffe ist nicht die einzige
strafe wie china entwickelt bericht
china hat möglicherweise eine neue
elektromagnetische woche getestet aber
was genau handelt es sich bei dieser
elektromagnetischen waffe nun es gibt
zwei möglichkeiten die
elektromagnetische kräfte im kampf
einzusetzen und eine es spektakulärer
als die andere wobei chinas fortschritte
bei beiden geradezu atemberaubend sind
auf der einen seite erleben wir gerade
die entstehung wichtiger emp waffen das
sind geräte die einen starken
elektromagnetischen impuls aus senden
können ein solcher angriff kann das
gesamte elektrische system eines landes
lahmlegen alle nicht ausreichend
abgeschöpft und elektrischen geräte
einfrieren und nein das ist keine
verschwörungstheorie oder verrückte
fantasie sondern bereits heute realität
natürlich auch für einen ausreichend
staaten enorme mengen an energie und wo
könnte man diese herbekommen hast du
eine idee nur zb durch atomwaffen wir
reden hier über einen ganz speziellen
typ von atomraketen die zwar auf
wasserstoff oder thermonukleare bomben
aufbauen jedoch in ihrer wirkung etwas
kastriert sind in großer höhe über dem
angriffsort gezündet erzeugen sie einen
riesigen elektromagnetischen impuls
jedoch ohne die üblichen zerstörerischen
auswirkungen eines konventionellen
thomas die schwelle feuerball und
radioaktiver fallout das chaos das sie
mit dmb verursachen ist jedoch immens
und kann den verein praktische wäre
unfähig gegen einen angriff mit
konventionellen truppen machen china ist
in der lage das us stromnetz mit einer
elektromagnetischen epos waffen erst
schlag abzuschmelzen beeindruckt nun
warte bis du siehst was china mit einem
einfachen bot anstellen kann die
protagonisten elektromagnetische rail
gangs und diejenigen von euch die sich
mit wochen auskennen werden sagen aber
mag die sind doch echt nichts neues und
ja es stimmt die konzeptionelle idee ist
ziemlich alt und reicht bis zum zweiten
weltkrieg zurück der unterschied
zwischen denen von damals und den
heutigen liegt in ihrer anwendung und
natürlich in der verbesserung ihrer
stärke und präzision in china tauchte
2018 in rohan eine riesige
elektromagnetische wellen auf die am bug
des schiffes seien schon montiert war
diese art von waffe ist nicht gerade
eine strafe da sie ein projektil
abfeuert aber sie tut dies indem sie auf
zwei parallelen stromführenden schienen
montiert wird die ein magnetfeld
erzeugen
dadurch kann das projektil in der kanone
dank der lohans kraft auf über
schallgeschwindigkeit beschleunigt
werden auf diese weise vervielfacht die
zerstörungs wirkung bei starte prozent
erzielen wie zum beispiel kriegsschiff
genau aus diesem grund china sie an bord
eines schiffes getestet denn peking
glaubt dass diese waffe seiner marine
eine überlegenheit auf dem see
verschaffen kann und natürlich ist die
zahlenmäßige und logische überlegenheit
der schlüssel zu chinas traum von der
kontrolle der meere im asiatisch
pazifischen raum ist besondere des
südchinesischen meeres und jetzt fragst
du dich sicher was ist mit den
restlichen waffen auf sich hat die wir
die in diesem video vorstellen wollen
also los geht's
über den wolken
erinnerst du dich an den legendären
amerikanischen f 117 nighthawk jedes
selbst am flugzeug das die haba der
militärischen luftfahrt in seinen bann
zog und dessen hauptmerkmal es war der
erste unsichtbare bomber der welt zu
sein nun die stars technologie ist heute
nichts exklusives mehr tatsächlich haben
viele staaten mit mehr oder weniger
starken militärischen flugzeug
entwicklungsprogrammen diese technologie
bereits ganz oder teilweise übernommen
und natürlich ist china auch eines von
ihnen
[Musik]
es betritt die bühne die changer j-20
ein jagdflugzeug das zwar nicht die
gefundenen geometrische formen der es
117 aufweist aber dennoch ein
unsichtbares tankflugzeug der fünften
generation ist zumindest behauptet
peking die bis vor kurzem es handelt
sich um das erste kampfflugzeug mit
tarnkappen technologie das vollkommen
autark vom asiatischen riesen entwickelt
wurde ein flugzeug das angeblich mit
drei anderen fortschrittlichen
tarnkappen jägern konkurrieren soll
[Musik]
der amerikanischen f-22 und f-35 sowie
der russischen zu kroos 57 heute sind
sich jedoch viele experten auf diesem
gebiet einig dass die j-20 nicht die
anforderungen erfüllt um als com
flugzeug der fünften generation zu
gelten sondern irgendwo zwischen
generation vier bis viereinhalb
anzusiedeln ist china ist hier also
nicht als konkurrenzfähig mit den usa
oder russland und auch nicht mit relativ
klein und südkorea darüber haben wir
übrigens ein eigenes video gemacht hast
du dir über das symbol oder den link in
der beschreibung ansehen kannst das
größte gesprächsthema über die u 20 ist
daher nicht mal ihre wirkliche
kampfkraft sondern die art und weise wie
sie entwickelt wurde
[Musik]
denn diese story ist ein wahrer thriller
wir reden hier über einen der
ausgefeiltesten fälle von
militärspionage bei dem die us
tarnkappen jäger programme es 35 22
ausgespäht wurden ja das ist richtig
lockheed martin die entwicklungsfirma
dieser beiden modelle ist davon
überzeugt dass chinesische hacker im
jahr 2007 technische dokumente der f-35
gestohlen haben und auch in das netzwerk
eines australischen auftragnehmers im
entwicklungsprogramm eingedrungen sind
sie sind sich auch sicher dass das
chinesische modell technologie enthält
welche direkt aus dem fcs was sich
programm gestohlen wurde worauf sich
diese behauptungen stützen nun us
quellen zufolge ist das sensorsystem w20
fast identisch mit denen der f-22 und
nicht nur das sie scheint auch die s35
in so wichtigen dingen rada und
triebwerks kalibrierung zu kopieren das
china diebstahl westlicher
militärtechnologie im großen maßstab
betrat war lange zeit eher ein offenes
geheimnis aber in diesem fall bestätigt
sogar etwas lohnen der bei der us
regierung nicht gerade hohes ansehen
genießt das china tatsächlich viele
terabyte an daten mit geheimen
informationen über die f35 gestohlen hat
neue slogan dokumente zeigen dass die
chinesen hinter dem f-35 heck stecken
einer der militärischen traube pekings
war es schon immer ihren gewaltigen
abstand zur mächtigkeit der us
kampfflugzeug technologie zu verringern
oder gar eines tages zu schließen
derzeit sind experten der meinung dass
die eigenschaften des chinesischen top
modells denen seine amerikanischen
konkurrenten weit unterlegen sind und
das ist nicht in der lage wäre in einer
offenen konfrontation die lufthoheit zu
gewinnen trotzdem dürfen wir nicht
ignorieren dass seine entwicklung einen
entscheidenden schritt für die
chinesischen militär industrie darstellt
es ist sozusagen ihr erster großer
durchbruch auch wenn dieser nicht auf
eigener geisteskraft passiert sondern
eher auf dem diebstahl genialer ideen
anderer und auch wenn dies alles sehr
unehrenhaft klingt es gibt ja
grundsätzlich immer zwei akten um an
etwas wertvolles zu kommen entweder man
kauft oder baut es selbst oder man klaut
es eben und wenn man mit letzteren
durchkommt ist es am ende ja egal ob der
sieger ehrenhaft gewonnen hat oder nicht
schreibt die geschichte ja oben und der
verlierer guckt auf jeden fall in die
röhre und genau diese gefahr trost
taiwan ohne die s35 könnte es für die
inselrepublik sehr schwierig werden
einen massiven angriff der j-20
abzuwehren genau aus diesem grunde
battle die taiwanesische regierung schon
seit jahren bei den usa ihn ein paar
f-35 zu verkaufen aber die amis haben
die sache bisher immer hinausgezögert
vielleicht käme es für sie einen
riesigen modell in frage das bisher aber
auch noch nicht zustande kam
kfz verkäufe anteil daran und das
komplexe macht gleichgewicht zwischen
den usa und china teil waren wollte f
35b senkrechtstarter kaufen um im falle
eines überraschungsangriff der
chinesischen volksbefreiungsarmee auf
taiwanesische flugplätze welche die
start und landebahn außer gefecht setzen
würden der lufthoheit zu behalten die
versuche den verkauf auszuhandeln wurden
jedoch von der obama-regierung vereitelt
die teilwahlen stattdessen das f 16
upgrade-paket anbot es scheint also
wolle washington dieses politische fast
einfach nicht aufmachen dabei stellen
die s35 für taipeh einen sehr wichtigen
faktor darum den expansionsgelüste
pekings unter gesamt die stirn bieten zu
können der in bislang besteht die
amerikanische antwort und darin von zeit
zu zeit flugzeugträger mit essen 30 in
die region zu verlegen aber die
taiwanesin sind sich nicht sicher ob die
usa im falle eines echten chinesischen
angriffs in den kampf eingreifen würden
und wollen deswegen logischerweise ihre
eigenen häfen 30 haben denn die top 20
ist nicht die einzige chinesische ist es
betrug der asiatische riese arbeitet
auch eine entwicklung des
fortschrittlichen drohnen modells der wj
7 unter
zusammen mit der unsichtbaren skyhawk
drohne könnte china in ländlicher
umgebung aufklären und dann aus großer
höhe zu schlagen die videos 700 ist ein
gewaltiger qualitätssprung in
chinesischen grundprogramm denn sie ist
die einzige chinesische
hochgeschwindigkeits drohne mit großer
reichweite die in der lage ist fünf
einsätze durchzuführen insbesondere kann
sie in verschiedenen situationen luft
boden präzisions schläge ausführen was
sie fast auf eine stufe mit den
modernsten us-drohnen stellt der vorteil
den diese art von waffe peking bei
seinen auslandseinsätzen verschaffen
würde könnte pekings militärische und
diplomatische strategie in zukunft
verändern und das sind nur einige der
vielen neuen waffen die hinein zur
einsatzfähigkeit bringen wird es gibt
noch viele viele weitere in allen formen
und farben einschließlich eines ganzen
kampfsystems für den krieg im weltall ja
genau china entwickelt ein ersatzsystem
zur zerstörung von satelliten mithilfe
von weltraumraketen eine fähigkeit an
der die sowjetunion trio des kalten
kriegs gearbeitet hat
und dann sind da noch die themen
gentechnisch veränderte viren und cyber
kriegsführung über die wir bald separate
videos reden werden also abo und löschen
nicht vergessen denn es wird alles
andere als langweilig china liegt immer
noch weiter in die usa zurück und die
amis treiben natürlich ihre eigenen
technologisch fortschrittlichen waffen
programm mit hochdruck voran
so einfach lassen sich die krone in
sachen superwaffen nicht abjagen aber
chinas karten liegen nun auf dem tisch
und sie zeigen deutlich dass energie
waren kampfflugzeuge der fünften
generation und fortschrittliche drohen
eine schlüsselrolle spielen werden hinzu
kommen die über raketen mit denen die
chinesischen streitkräfte die us-marine
obsolet machen wollen
china testet neue weltraum fähigkeiten
mit hyperschall raketen dass statt einer
nuklearer bestückung wegen rakete im
august die den globus umkreiste
überraschte die us geheimdienste aber
jetzt bist du an der reihe glaubst du
dass china in der lage sein wird die
stärke der usa im asiatisch pazifischen
raum zu übertreffen wie immer sind wir
auch all eure meinung zu diesem thema
schon gespannt ich hoffe also dass euch
die video gefallen wird falls ja gibt es
mit einem like teil dessen folgen und
vergesst nicht das abo mit glöckchen um
keines unserer videos mehr verpassen was
gut und ist weiter
[Musik]